assurer la sécurité de la transformation
numérique avec le développement du
digital la cybersécurité devient un
enjeu important
l'apparition berwick forum européen de
l'économie numérique a permis d'informer
d'échanger de faire de la pédagogie sur
cette activité
nous pensons que si nous voulons
transformer la société et intégrer
l'impact numérique il faut absolument
que ce soit avec la confiance des
utilisateurs à la confiance là qu'est la
cybersécurité kivu la porte
en parallèle la délégation officielle de
cet événement s'est rendu au ski cube
présents notamment des représentants de
pays européens comme l'estonie ou la
finlande des échanges informels sur
leurs expériences concept le secteur
public créé les concepts la manière dont
la cyber sécurité nationale devrait
ressembler et après nous incluons et
nous demandons secteur privé de fournir
les services et les produits
la politique va être de plus en plus
importante je dois dire cela et je suis
très heureux par exemple quand je lis la
nouvelle stratégie cyber de la france et
de voir le nombre d'hommes politiques se
pencher sur cette question c'est quelque
chose que nous devons apprendre dans les
autres pays européens dès maintenant
avec une trentaine d'entreprises
engagées dans la cybersécurité
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaite
développer un campus dans ce domaine en
collaboration notamment avec
l'université versailles saint quentin
déformation de la recherche et d'autres
activités proposées une composante
centre d'entraînement pour pouvoir parer
aux différentes attaques
et puis bien sûr comme on nous l'avons
essayée à skis cube une composante
start-up incubateur pour développer les
entreprises de demain en matière de
cybersécurité à saint quentin en
yvelines
ce projet est en cours d'élaboration
objectif pour 2022 regrouper deux mille
étudiants spécialisés en cyber sécurité